what's going on uh well he's been
arrested was arrested at the airport
Charlie Shrem
24 years old arrested today and charged
with engaging in money-laundering with a
with a user at Silk Road now Georgia you
would call that Silk Road was that
infamous black-market drug website often
referred to as essentially the eBay for
drugs SRAM ran a site that enabled
people to transfer money from Bitcoin to
cash via his company called bit instant
now according to this federal criminal
complaint he is charged with three
counts one count of operating an
unlicensed money transmitting business
in other words you can't be Western
Union without falling under some
guidelines one kind of money laundering
conspiracy one count of willful failure
to file a suspicious activity report now
the other point the DEA DEA is making is
that Schrempf bought drugs online at
Silk Road and that he knew Silk Road was
a trafficking web site Adam and I
actually visited Charlie's nightclub
here in the city it's called EVR and it
was actually one of the first places in
Manhattan to take Bitcoin last year we
talked to him about the risks he was
facing he did make the point that the
feds were breathing down his back every
single day here's an excerpt from that
interview take a listen what
risks the legal risk do you think to you
well if you if you asked me last week I
tell you that the legal risk is that
simply we don't know what Bitcoin is we
don't know what the government says
about it we don't know what the
government thinks about it we don't know
how they're going to treat it we don't
know anything so my company that's
existing and that's paying salaries and
is doing all these things we don't know
where we fallen into any legal framework
well the feds certainly seem to be
making a statement now or at least
trying to here I think one of the big
questions is just what's going to happen
over the next several months Deirdre in
other words how does this currency ever
really become legit if the federal
government really seems to fundamentally
and they do have a problem with it and
we know the Winklevoss twins who
obviously were featured in the movie
about facebook they're actually
investors in Schramm's company yeah you
know a lot of people are very excited by
this idea they like the idea that you
can have a currency that is not tied to
any kind of central bank sort of
philosophically it's exciting it makes
sense you know people are saying this
could be the new gold you have all this
coin that needs to be mined all over the
internet but at the same time I mean
think about it if you're if you're you
know if you're in the federal government
you don't like the idea that people
could effectively use another form of
cash to buy things that they shouldn't
be buying online now Charlie has told me
and would tell you Charlie Shrem that in
fact it's not completely anonymous in
other words the feds can track you down
and in this particular case they seem to
have tracked him down but it makes it
certainly much much more difficult and
that lends concern to a lot of different
things for example terrorist financing
it makes it more challenging for the
feds to track money